sachez que tout ce qui se dit ici si on
ne vous et moi c'est off the record de
cette semaine la liberté de presse a été
sérieusement malmenés avec huit
journalistes de différents médias qui
ont été espionnés par la police de
montréal et la sûreté du québec
c'est inusité la liberté de presse les
gens les gens sont morts la liberté de
presse c'est une chasse généraliser les
journalistes dans leur travail c'est un
rouage essentiel de démocratie qu est-ce
que c'est un baromètre de la démocratie
et liberté presse complètement
complètement ce l'idée d'un big brother
est quand même très choquant
aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'il ya
une fragilité il ya une vulnérabilité
des médias et des journalistes
avec les moyens techniques qui sont les
nôtres on se rend compte que la
surveillance devient de plus en plus
facile le canada est maintenant 18e au
classement mondial de la liberté de
presse de reporters sans frontières un
recul de 10 points par rapport à 2015 en
raison surtout de l'accès difficile à
l'ancien premier ministre fédéral et des
craintes liées à la loi antiterroriste
si évidemment si on commence à regarder
ce qui se passe dans le monde et je
parlerai même pas de la turquie
je parle même pas de société où on sait
que les médias sont ou sous tutelle ou
sous surveillance ou des journalistes de
l'opposition sont arrêtés ou empêchés de
travailler
jusqu'ici en 2016 cinquante quatre
journalistes ont été tuées et cent
soixante dix emprisonnés en raison
d'activités liées à leur travail
toujours selon en reporters sans
frontières pourquoi une source acceptent
de parler parce que des risques à le
faire il ya d'abord le fait que quand on
est une source il ya un phénomène de
valorisation on a quelque chose à dire
il ya aussi des gens qui sont animés par
le fait de dénoncer un certain nombre de
situations d et pour stopper le problème
une des façons de procéder c'est
d'alerter les médias tout en restant
protéger et pour garantir un anonymat
total c'est de ne pas utiliser ni le
téléphone cellulaire ni les médias
sociaux est autrement dit revenir à des
vieilles méthodes si j'ose dire de
rencontrer ces sources
si watine merci beaucoup je vous en prie